what's up guys bang bang this was a big
week in the Bitcoin industry Bitcoin is
officially the number one performing
asset during q1 Bitcoin is up about 70
to start the year and bitcoin's
correlation with gold continues to rise
and now it's hit near all-time highs as
we've seen with Bitcoin people are
running to the digital currency in times
of chaos and uncertainty some people
were seeking out Bitcoin because the
debt limit crisis and the fear that the
United States May default other people
were running to bitcoin because they
thought that the Fed was gonna pivot
return to QE and Bitcoin would do well
in that environment and some people were
simply going to bitcoin because of the
banking crisis and the fear that Savings
in the bank account may not be as safe
as they previously thought regardless of
the reason Bitcoin had an absolute
monster start to the year and was the
best performing asset in q1 now Michael
Saylor and microstrategy they've bought
more Bitcoin and they now are the proud
owners of about 140 000 Bitcoin Michael
Saylor also reportedly owns personally
about 17 000 Bitcoin as well that brings
his ownership between the company and
his personal Bitcoin to about point
seven five percent nearing in on that
one percent magic number many people are
wondering if Michael Saylor owns almost
one percent of Bitcoin is that a problem
or risks introduced you have to remember
that whether you own a hundred and forty
thousand Bitcoin or you simply own one
everyone has the same amount of control
over the protocol that is the beauty of
a decentralized protocol like Bitcoin no
matter how much Bitcoin you own everyone
has the same amount of control do not
confuse Bitcoin ownership with ownership
of nodes or of hash power and last but
not least Apple went ahead and they put
a little Easter egg in the brand new Mac
if you go into the terminal command line
you can search around and find a hidden
copy of the Bitcoin white paper this is
one of the most valuable companies in
the world there are millions and
millions and millions of Mac users all
around the globe hope and now they're
promoting the Bitcoin white paper and
doing so in this Easter egg fashion only
creates more online conversation and
spreads the word further it'll be
interesting to see will Apple continue
to embrace Bitcoin will they eventually
put Bitcoin in their balance sheet could
they potentially build all sorts of
payment products to engage with the
decentralized payment Network or is this
simply a one-off and maybe it was an
internal employee who just thought it'd
be funny I don't know but it's something
to keep an eye on that's it for this
week I hope you enjoyed these updates
and I'll see everyone again next
Saturday